everyone hates Jake Paul but he is an  absolute genius that took the smart  routes see most Fighters slave away  working a dead-end job training like a  dog taking fights for like two thousand  dollars while taking brain damage all in  the hopes of being the best only to find  out that being the best is very very  very hard while Jake Paul he's not the  best but he built up an audience first  he built up marketing skills first he  built up a giant pool of people that  actually care if he gets knocked out or  not that is why he deserves every single  penny he's made everyone May hate him  but it doesn't matter because they're  the ones that will buy the pay-per-view  they're the ones that will buy the  tickets to see him live they're the  reason he made 40 million dollars last  year from boxing see Jake Paul  understands a fundamental truth in this  world it doesn't matter how good you are  if no one knows who you are subscribe  for more because